-Jimmy, I love you so much.
Hi, guys.
-John Stamos in the house.
-Can I start by saying --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can I just say
I love you so much?
You bring so much.
You probably --
You need to hear this. You bring
so much joy to this world.
You make people so happy,
especially me.
So God bless you. And thank you.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Isn't he the best?
I compare you to, like,
the greats,
like Sinatra,
Sammy Davis, Elvis.
You commit 100%
to everything you do,
every show, every segment,
every game show you do.
-I was going to say
the same about you,
but now it's going to seem fake.
-It'd be weird, yeah.
-But I really loved
working with you
on "That's My Jam."
-That was great.
-I will get into all of that.
I want to talk about the memoir.
-Sure.
-"If You Would Have Told Me."
-Yes.
Is it about "if you would have
told me that I would be --"
-I'd be here
with Jimmy Fallon.
I never would have believed it.
Seriously.
-Am I in the book?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Now you have to add it.
-I talk about
losing my virginity.
Oh, you know what?
-Save it for that.
-No. You know what's
interesting?
My mother-in-law,
who I love, you know,
and she's been in education
for 30 years.
She's got a degree
in journalism.
I said, "Well,
take a look at the first
three chapters for me,
will you?"
"Okay. Okay." And I told
Caitlin, my wife,
and she said, "No!"
I go, "What?" She goes,
"At the end of chapter three,
you talk about losing
your virginity...graphically."
I'm like, "Oh, God."
-Oh, my God!
-And so I called her
and I said, "Hi, Leilani."
-"How far are you in the book?"
-Well, exactly. Yeah.
I said hi.
She said, "Hello, John."
So I was like, "Oh, God."
I said, "You know,
the end of that chapter --"
"Yes. You know, you're married
to my daughter. I know."
-Oh, my God.
-She said, "You know,
my grandson."
"I know, I know.
Listen, I'm sorry.
They wanted me to put
some sex stuff in there.
And it's throughout the book."
And she says,
"What?
Oh, no, you're John Stamos.
Of course you're going
to talk about sex.
Your grammar is terrible."
[ Laughter ]
-That's a teacher right there.
That's a good teacher.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is exactly right.
Get your head out of the gutter.
Your grammar is terrible.
-Exactly.
-You know, I can't help
but think about
but who would have laughed
at that is our pal Bob Saget,
who just had an unbelievable
sense of humor.
And I'm sure he's a big part
of this book.
-He is, yeah. I talk about him
in the beginning
and sort of all the way through,
and you were so kind to send me
a nice note when he passed away.
You know, I just feel awful that
he didn't know how loved he was
because the world --
When he died,
could you believe that tsunami
of love that came out?
It was the first time
I was ever jealous of him.
[ Laughter ]
I'm kidding.
It just breaks my heart
that he didn't know
because he didn't.
But he never left anything
on the table. You know that.
And so if he loved you, he said,
"I love you
and I'm proud of you."
So let's keep
his legacy alive by doing --
If you're with somebody, say,
"I love you, I'm proud of you.
God bless you,"
that kind of thing.
-Yeah, why not?
Everyone do that.
Just look
at each other and say it.
-I love you.
-Say it as much as you can.
I love you.
-I love you.
-I love you, Roots.
-I love Quest the best.
-Yeah. Here's you, by the way,
at the drum set here.
Because you play -- You
performed with The Beach Boys.
-Yes.
-This is a big --
That's amazing.
-It's the thrill of my life.
-And then look at this thrill
of your life right here.
-Yeah.
-How old is Billy?
-He's going to be five
next week.
And that's just one other kid
upstaging me in my life.
[ Laughter ]
Right?
-Is it the best thing?
-It's the best.
You have two daughters.
How old are they?
-Nine and eight.
-I saw them on the show
quite a bit, on your show.
-They didn't know that
they were on the show.
It was COVID time. They didn't
even know what was happening.
They thought
it was on the phone.
They didn't know
we were airing anything.
So I think they would be shy if
I brought them out or anything.
-They're so cute.
Yeah, he doesn't like and I say,
"Do you want to watch?"
"That's My Jam." I said,
"Oh." Finally I thought,
"He's going to like that show"
because he watches "Full House,"
but he mocks me for it.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "You know, Billy,
can you put your toys away?"
He'd go, "You got it, dude."
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-I love this kid!
[ Applause ]
I love this kid.
-So I thought he would
really like "That's My Jam."
So we put it on and he watches
and goes, "You're cheating."
I'm like, "I'm not cheating."
-Yeah, you were.
-I was not.
-No, I wasn't.
-Yeah, he's right.
-What?
-You cheated.
-No, I didn't.
-Yeah.
-I did?
-Where?
-I actually have a picture
of you cheating.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, this is where --
-Let's see.
-Well, the idea of the game
is someone's doing charades
while the wall spins around,
so you're not supposed to see
what they're seeing.
But here's you actually
peeking around the wall
and cheating.
[ Laughter ]
You're not supposed to do that.
You were so funny and charming
and talented on this show.
Can I just say this?
You can plug your ears
about this, but man, oh, man,
it was charming.
Yeah. Everything I just said.
You did this one game
where we had random instruments
and you had to pick up
and you had to try to play out
the note of a song or somehow
get someone to guess the song.
-Right.
-And we don't rig it.
You don't know what songs
you're getting or anything.
You picked up this, like, bass
ukulele or something.
-I don't know what that was.
-And played
"Play That Funky Music
White Boy"
and you picked up
and you're like, "Boom, boom,
ba boom, ba boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
I was like, professionally.
-Yeah.
-People went nuts,
-Quinta said
he's actually a white
boy playing that funky music.
[ Laughter ]
-It actually did happen. White
boy was playing that --
-Thank you for
having me on that show.
It was so fun.
-The whole band
was looking like,
"Yo, this guy could play, man."
-And we won.
I was happy to be nominated,
but we won.
-Yeah. Exactly.
You did win.
You and Taraji, winning team.
Buddy, I will do anything
with you
and any idea you come up with
or anything.
-Really? Okay.
-I love you.
-I love you, too.
I really do.
I've just been such a big fan of
you for so long.
-But every time you come
on the show,
you've done bits with Bob.
You've done bits by yourself.
And "That's My Jam."
If you honestly --
-What about that song
I sang on there?
Will you do that with me?
They had me doing
weird lyrics to "YMCA,"
but it was like I shared
an Uber with Tim Chalamet.
-Yeah.
-Which you'll get it stuck --
It's an earwig and my wife has
been singing it in bed, which...
-♪ I took an Uber with ♪
♪ Tim Chalamet ♪
♪ Not the actor, just some guy
from L.A. ♪
-Again, you don't know what
those lyrics are going to be.
So you're reading the
teleprompter for the first time.
We actually have a clip.
Here's John Stamos
singing nonsense karaoke
on "That's My Jam."
Take a look at this.
-♪ Plump hands ♪
♪ Can't wear gloves
when it snows ♪
♪ I watch C-Span ♪
♪ With a grape up my nose ♪
♪ My ex-girlfriend ♪
♪ Looks like Optimus Prime ♪
♪ Hold on, Craig...wants...me
to...FaceTime ♪
Can't right now, Craig.
Here we go.
♪ I split an Uber with ♪
♪ Tim Chalamet ♪
♪ Not the actor,
just some guy from L.A. ♪
I can't get that out of my mind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're wearing beards.
You look good with a beard.
-You too.
-That's for a movie, right?
-It was. Yeah.
-When that movie comes out,
please come back.
-I would love to. Thank you.
-You are more than welcome.
We love you every
single -- You come --
Don't even leave.
Stay the whole week.
It's John Stamos Week
here on "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Check out "That's My Jam" but
also preorder his memoir,
"If You Would Have Told Me."
Preorder it right now.